this is fascinating because you're there
is a local medical office
where you can get a detailed look inside
your body before signs
or symptoms of something as serious as
say a heart attack
or other ailments occur dr john pierce
with preventative diagnostic center is
here to tell us
more about that dr pierce it is good to
see you this is
pretty unique technology for the valley
tell us what it looks like
well it looks like uh it's a simple ct
scan
what's beautiful about it is you're not
stuck in a tunnel like an mri
so our skin's able to be done in about
20 to 40 seconds so people are in and
out of it
the uniqueness of the scanner is that it
actually measures the individual going
in
so it gives them the lowest effective
dose of radiation
that allows us to get the most pristine
imaging for our radiologist to read
it picks up a number of ailments
including heart disease or shows
indications of it
which of course is a silent killer a lot
of times there are no symptoms until
a major heart attack how does the scan
detect a heart attack before it occurs
absolutely so basically we're looking at
the coronary arteries and we can see
coronary artery disease by plaque
buildup that gets calcified
and that calcification lights up on that
ct scan
so if there's significant amount of
calcification we know that there's a
significant amount of heart disease
now we're unable to tell if back
calcification is impeding blood flow to
the heart muscle
so we highly recommend people to go see
a cardiologist if they have a high score
because the cardiologist can then do the
proper testing to see
if there's you know blood flow that's
being slowed down and
in a lot of cases we've sent people uh
and they've
been found to have 80 90 blockages i've
been told hey
these folks were sitting on a time bomb
cardiologist seen them
put a stent in and really saved their
life and possibly extended their life as
well
so good that they uh got ahead of that
what is the ideal patient for you
as far as age range gender whatever it
might be
uh males and females 40 to 70 years old
75 years old
that's kind of the the ideal range and
then you know people that are concerned
and want to take control of their health
they want peace of mind
a lot of times you know you get uh we've
had patients come in that have been
given you know kind of a blessing by
their primary care doctor or
cardiologist based off of
lab tests and a physical exam then we do
the scan and it shows underlying
conditions
that absolutely need attention that were
they were not going to be found unless
they did the scan
yeah so someone gets a scan and
obviously doctors look at it how long
before they get a report
we get the report within 24 to 48 hours
unless there's something wrong
and then typically we wait until i can
get into the office
and talk to the patient because i want
to call somebody or sit down and talk
with them
to explain exactly what we found because
a lot of times if
you know the late person reads it boy
they get on dr google and it scares the
bejesus out of them so
i want to be able to explain it to them
keep them calm and get them pointed in
the right direction so they can head
this off at the pass
dr google has scared many people over
the years dr
peterson thanks so much for joining us
appreciate it
you can call preventative diagnostics
diagnostic center
at 702-534-7900
or you can find them online at that web
address
pdcenterlv.com they have a special offer
right now
a heart scan with calcium score for 125
dollars which is
a significant deal because normally it
is 599 dollars